okay here we go
another game with this my way one of the
opponents i've played so often and
um he's down to a really
low rating for his standard
he's he's a pretty pretty decent player
but
usually he's got like 2 300 or something
and
now he's here with 2125
of course really strange
move order here can i make use of this
somehow
no idea i really don't
want to go for the usual g3 setup
maybe i can i can do something
entertaining here
h5 this is possible
no idea looks interesting
now c5 maybe to have bishop c4
so
h6
didn't really expect that one
yeah and maybe just just give the check
here
in order to encourage him okay
he doesn't want to play d5 what about
knight g5
now knight g5 he takes on g5 queen h5
bishop h6 bishop takes g5 hmm
isn't this dangerous
it looks dangerous
of course you can go to g6 but
yeah so i don't want to spend um
ages on this
yeah so what now
do i have um something
really nice here bishop
e2 he just takes i guess
this won't work
of course i can i can go on knight e6
it should be the simple move
not a bad one i guess
okay
knight f3 uh queen f3 for instance
in order to switch to h3o
or something else entirely
yeah if it takes on d4 i just have to
cast along i guess and hope for the best
this attack isn't really um
correct of course in a
mathematical sense but
it's interesting to to try out
usually is he is he's a very slow player
and it's actually surprising that he
still
has got more than three minutes left i'm
already down to two
which is usual for me i guess
okay i need i need to play quicker
yeah it's an interesting position it's
not uh
not entirely clear i guess
what now
what about knight e4 if he takes queen
takes e4
he needs to go rook f5 then bishop e6
looks interesting if he if he retreats
the rook
then i got at least knight to g3
and then i'm on i'm on h5
also after the rook retreat i can go um
i can go rook h1 and then
maybe he needs to play king h7 then
interesting
interesting
rook h1 king h7
knight g5 takes rook take to h5
bishop h6
bishop taj takes g5
wow okay
he simply um gives away the rook
for now
yeah do i want to take it huh
time for play this one i think i think
it still has to
has to go on rook h king h7
here if he takes d5 i take
h5 and e8 is hanging
yeah i guess now i have to take
well what a structure
um does he threaten anything
this one
take here takes d5 maybe i can i can
just take here
and then this one
i know it's uh
not really a mating attack but
it's got a completely ruined pawn
structure
i'm on my way to a4 with the rook
i didn't see this one oh my
check
check
check check
check
game drawn well with half a second left
okay yeah very very complicated game i
guess
this attack was uh not correct
on the the first couple of moves but
it just got really interesting maybe it
was um
even even good for me at some point but
i still spend far too much time on this